Leute kurz an alle die mich gerade daran
erinnern mit dem mit dem Kürbis zu
machen danke schön wir machen heute den
prank mit dem Kürbis also Leute ich
brauche wieder
[Musik]
die ganze Pool schwimmt über wenn du da
reingehst ich weiß nicht so witzig dass
das hier einfach guck mal das geht
einfach nicht raus
[Musik]
wie geil das sieht aus wie ein
Wackelpudding so ein blauer
Handy ja
das ist jetzt nicht dein Ernst das ist
jetzt nicht dein Ernst
[Musik]
sag mir mal bitte was du gerade gegessen
hast ein Apfel
wir haben den goldapfel und wo ist denn
einfach so
weißt du wie verdammt selten diese
goldäpfel waren die wir hatten das habe
ich ihn jetzt gecheckt ganz wichtige
Sachen ich bin gerade auf Mut komm jetzt
in meine versteckte Kiste
so nein nein
was will der denn jetzt Leute schreibt
der hey ich hoffe er hat nicht irgendein
scheiß geplant der alte mit einem
Barriere an ja wäre ja Block Alter Serie
immer wieder ne ich hoffe sie hat jetzt
keinen großen prank geplant Leute
ich habe nämlich eingeplant bin auf dem
Youtube natürlich äh mit dem Kürbis ich
möchte einen Kürbis machen den Sandra
aufsetzt aber dann nicht mehr absetzen
kann außer sie bringt sich um
[Musik]
ey Sirius ist so ein ne der hat
mich eingebaut was ist denn da für eine
Party
ich mache mir in die Hosen
Sandy
ich hatte TNT hier in der Box drin gib
mir das jetzt wieder
[Musik]
ich verstehe
wieder vom Server gesperrt gib mir jetzt
mein TNT
ich bin der Richter hier Sandy gib mal
TNT wieder hat Sirio geschrieben guck
Sirius der Friedensrichter kommen wir
treffen uns im Café ja wir haben keinen
Kaffee klar wir haben eine Wurstbude
komm wir treffen uns im Café wir reden
im Café jetzt und dann klären wir den
Scheiß
oder wie erklärt es ach jetzt hat er uns
ja eingebaut ja selfie was soll das
warum glaubst du wieder die Sachen
ja jetzt komm auf den Punkt sonst würde
ich dich einfach mir egal guck mal die
Klauen mir schon Sachen und anstatt dass
ich sie bestrafe gebe ich dir noch die
Chance mit dir zu reden
ja das sind nicht alle TNT okay tschüss
mein Gott junge
hey jetzt ist es egal
ich habe dir wirklich die Chance gegeben
du läufst die ganze Zeit von mir weg so
und jetzt geht's endlich mal an den
pferdestallieren möchtest du mir dabei
mithelfen sandra ist gemutet ja dafür
das Handy nicht redet ist ja
wahrscheinlich eh nicht mit am Start
[Musik]
hey das ist doch nicht wahr
was machst du hier
was
[Musik]
wie was mache ich was ist das hier für
ein Klotz
welcher Platz ey die tritt alle Regeln
mit Füßen was haben wir denn für regeln
wir haben gesagt wenn wir irgendetwas
bauen in unserer Welt besprechen wir das
Miteinander
rückgängig machen
was macht der Kerl
was macht Siri oder da ich kann komplett
ab ich bin geistig ganz gesund
[Applaus]
nein
Minecraft gesehen
[Musik]
oh wie süß
aber gleichzeitig
die sehen bisschen aus wie Sandy du
kleiner so kann man irgendwie mitnehmen
eine Ewigkeit später ich habe ein
Geschenk für dich jetzt hier habe ich
extra für Dich mitgebracht
[Musik]
die kannst du gerne selber behalten
Laser jetzt hat meine Kröte Kürbis prank
guter call ich weiß halt nicht wie ich
Fluch der Bindung hinkriegen soll weil
ich kein Buch mit Fluch der Bindung habe
hey Sirio wenn du mich gerade hörst
kannst du mir vielleicht
einen
ein Buch mit dem Effekt Fluch der
Bindung geben
dann muss ich mir das nicht cheaten
Sandra merkt dass logischerweise nicht
dann kannst du mir das einfach
hinschmeißen weil ich habe einen
lustigen prank geplant
[Musik]
also Leute ganz kurze Info wir haben
natürlich auch für heute wieder einen
prank geplant denn ich benötige einen
Kürbis muss den schnitzen mit meiner
Schere benötige dann eine Fackel und das
Fluch der bindungsbuch denn gebe ich
Sandra nämlich diesen Kürbis und sage
hey hey setzt sie mal auf lustig hast
den Kürbiskopf dafür brauche ich
vielleicht auch sogar einen zweiten
damit ich erstmal zeigen wie das geht
und das ist kein Problem darstellt und
dann setze ich stirbt
mal schauen ob das ganze klappt ich
liebe Wirklich leider alles
ja dann habe ich noch meinen
allerletztes Geschenk für dich heute
denn du weißt ja wir wollen bald ins
Ende gehen
wenn man ins Ende geht in Minecraft muss
man sich einen Kürbis aufsetzen ihr so
dann hat man den geschnitzten Kürbis auf
okay
ich gebe dir jetzt auch ein dann haben
wir beide quasi so ein Kürbiskopf weil
wenn du damit no joke ich schwöre auf
meine Mutter damit kannst du Enderman
angucken also ich schwöre wirklich dann
kannst du Enderman in die Augen gucken
und ich glaube das ist für dich das
sinnvoll was machen kannst als Kopf
anziehen ne als Helm ja sehr gut siehst
du irgendwie anders gerade ja so aus wie
es gerade bei dir aussieht aber du
kannst jetzt einfach wieder abnehmen
aber damit kannst du wirklich Enderman
angucken
[Musik]
was ist
verstehe dich nicht wegen deinem Mikro
ich kann dir doch auch einfach abnehmen
schau doch bei mir geht's doch auch
sieht besser aus als vorher
Animal Crossing ich bin raus mit
Minecraft
[Musik]
Nummer hast gelöscht
guck mal jetzt Entschuldigung setze ich
in den Kürbislaterne ins Haus
auch wenn ich wieder dieses Bett rum ne
auch wenn wir jetzt das mit dem
Pferdestall heute leider nicht
hingekriegt einfach nicht war trotzdem
sehr schön in Minecraft heute war sehr
viel los mal wieder Leute mit Minecraft
was das jetzt
[Musik]